are you guys as excited as me for the
Battle of Winterfell no okay Sam how are
you doing you neither Sam God who is
gonna save us from the night king it's
gonna be Sir Jorah right
oh god no sir Jorah Theon oh jesus this
is a bloodbath
well the night king we'll just have to
wait because in this episode we'll be
delving into the Battle of Winterfell
and how the inhabitants of the Last
Stand faced off against the Lord of
Darkness this video is an analysis of
both the episode and the battle strategy
put forward by Jon Snow and the
resistance so if you're looking for a
tribute page for Lyanna Mormont this
isn't the place for you oh [ __ ] it the
episode can be split into six parts the
Dothraki attack the retreat the fire
trench The Last Stand Jon versus the
night king and our Diaz attack once you
put together the episode in that order
it becomes easier to understand so we'll
go through it piece by piece and uncover
some of the mysteries along the way but
before we get into that we must first
delve into the battle plan put forward
last episode the main theory revolves
around the night King exposing himself
so that they can put an end to him and
the undead if they kill him the theory
goes that the undead will follow because
bran has the mark of the night king
he'll be searching for him thus he'll be
used as bait in the godswood once the
undead army gets too close or Davos will
be in charge of waving the torch to
signal Dany and Jon to light the
trenches something he does do but
because the encroaching snowstorm Dany
and John are unable to see it there's
also the question about whether dragon
fire will be able to stop the night king
a question which is answered later on
this episode Dany using dragon fire
against the night King according to bran
makes this the first time anyone has
tried such tactics against the night
king the first part of the battle plan
is the Dothraki attack there's a great
long shot almost two minutes long that
starts with Sam as he ventures through
at Winterfell and we see the unsullied
preparing citizens prepping for the
crypt Lyanna gathering her forces tear
preparing and bran being shipped to the
weirwood tree by thea and alice Karstark
the troops fall into place as a calm
draws over the crowd the anticipation of
battle is palpable throughout all the
combatants and I love how Podrick
Brienne and Jamie are side by side even
Gendry in the Hound make their way to
the front with Edison and Sam and look
even captain friendzone has made his way
to the front line okay I should actually
stop with the friendzone jokes because
Jorah is badass and oh I'm getting ahead
of myself
but perhaps the most surprising reveals
that pearance of Milla Sandra who asked
Joe if he speaks the Dothraki tongue she
tells them to lift their swords so she
can bless them with the power of light
making their blades flame like beric
Dondarrion and come on this is just
badass Jorah leads the Dothraki into
battle well Milla saundra gives the high
Valyrian saying Valar morghulis
meaning all men must die which is
responded by grain worm with valor to
horus meaning all men must serve it's
interesting that Davos is the one to let
me lissandra through the gate
considering their history she was the
one who convinced Stannis to burn his
own daughter for God's sakes that
daughter taught him how to read she even
tells Davos when they meet there's no
need to execute her she'll be dead
before dawn as she shares a look with
Arya both women have banged kendry in
hint-hint
Melisandre will be dead before dawn
literally
the Dothraki commence their attack into
the darkness which can be seen through
their flaming cutlasses as Dany and John
watch on they see the lights of the
swords died out
the Dothraki in the blink of an eye are
completely destroyed that's like eight
seasons of building this army gone in
two minutes what a start this leads us
into the second part of the Battle of
Winterfell the retreat which begins with
the remaining Dothraki and sir Jorah
clamoring back to Winterfell
unsuccessful and oh my god it's like a
tsunami of corpses that descend upon our
heroes Jaime even as a moment where he
saves his love from impending doom
before Dany and John bring their dragons
to the rescue but John has his eyes on
the night king and his commanders but a
sudden surge of frosty winds swerve him
off-course
Arya tells Sansa
head down to the Crypt giving sense a
dagger of dragonglass to protect herself
Podrick the hound Jaime Brienne and Sam
fight valiantly when Edison is killed
while helping Sam our first big death of
the episode hydrolyzed Danny and Jon
struggle against the harsh winds as the
army of undead press onward the
overwhelming force of undead forces
everyone to retreat back into Winterfell
the unsullied do their best to hold back
the undead but it isn't enough the sheer
onslaught is just too much there's even
a great moment of Arya killing a white
to save the Hound the man who is once on
her list to kill with the onslaught
being too much to handle grey worm
orders the trench to be lit which leads
us to the third part of the Battle of
Winterfell the lighting of the trench
because of the storm Danny can't see the
order to light the trench and since it's
so cold out even the flame arrows don't
work this means Milla Sandra must
venture out into the field of battle and
calling the Lord of Light to ignite the
flames for a woman whose intuition about
prophecies and belief in a Lord of Light
who's let her down so many times this is
a major feat and luckily for her it pays
off the lighting of the trench allows
Winterfell a brief moment of rest to
catch their breath and regroup also mad
props to Sansa telling Tyrion he was the
best of them referring to their marriage
it's a slight comfort in comedic release
during this serious battle he uh
apologizes to brand but bran is being
brand and just tells him it is what it
is before working into Ravens
giving him sight on the battlefield and
toward the night king this is the first
shot we've gotten of him since the
battle began with the undead tired of
waiting they begin to launch themselves
into the fire clearing a path for others
to make their way through this begins
the fourth part of the Battle of
Winterfell which I've called The Last
Stand it's here that the undead clamour
up the walls of Winterfell like zombies
from World War Z
the pile and pile upon each other making
the need for ladders completely useless
I mean come on just look at this
onslaught our heroes make a desperate
last stand but the sheer amount of
undead makes it impossible to overcome
they literally rain down on Winterfell
like a scourge but before it's over aria
is given a moment to shine completely
obliterating everything in her path this
spear Gendry made her all romantic and
look at this move aria literally tumbles
over a horde of zombies like a friggin
ninja it's only Arya's will terr survive
that sparks the Hound to rejoin the
battle he's been suffering from some
sort of PTSD but snaps out of it at the
sight of Aria and let's all pay our
respects to Liana who takes on a friggin
giant but gets squished in the process
not before taking him out of course it's
a rough night for house Mormons in the
air Danny and John are overwhelmed by
the night king and his dragon well Arya
creeps through the halls of Winterfell
swerving past zombies like Usain Bolt
it's a bit ironic that arya is saved by
beric Dondarrion a man who is once on
her kill list for selling Gendry to
Milla saundra here he is doing his best
Hodor impression last episode we learned
he was taken off Arya's list Milla
saundra appears and tells her barrack
was brought back for a purpose this
purpose being for him to save Aria so
she can eventually go on to kill the
night king Milla saundra even says Aria
will shut many eyes forever even blue
eyes a hint that she'll be the one to
kill the night king the knight king and
his dragon completely obliterate
Winterfell eventually getting into a
tussle with Jon and his dragon but Danny
saves the day and launches the night
King onto the battlefield this leads us
to the fifth part of a battle Jon versus
the night king it begins with Dany
lighting the night King on fire to no
avail apparently the night king can
withstand a dragon's flame but now it's
John's time to shine if a dragon can't
kill the night king surely John's blade
can but before Jon can get a job in the
night King pulls the same move he did in
hardhome by resurrecting the dead bodies
around him it looks like John is [ __ ]
out of luck not only that but the dead
bodies in Winterfell including Leanna
and Edison resurrect as well
and let me just say whoever's in charge
of cleaning up bodies after this battle
is in for one hell of a job even the
bodies in the start crypt emerge from
their tombs and now it's Theon's time to
shine as he tries to make amends for the
crimes he committed against the stark
family we'll get into that in a bit
meanwhile John is saved by his lover
Danny from a horde of zombies but her
dragon drogon is quickly overwhelmed
knocking her on the ground she's saved
by Jorah who defends her till his last
dying breath in the crypts there's an
amazing scene between Tyrion and Sansa
who both take out their blades as
they're overwhelmed by undead these
blades aren't to kill themselves rather
to go out in a blaze of glory in this
scene where Jon battles through the
courtyard is absolutely terrifying as
it's literally raining undead all around
them the night king makes his way to
brand with one final guardian protecting
him
Theon and he proves that you don't need
balls to truly be a man Fran's last
words give him vindication telling him
he's a good man and thanking him thus
Theon's character arc is complete and he
can die knowing he's achieved what he
set forth to do if only he waited a few
minutes for Arya am i right regardless
he's given a heroic death a complete
opposite from what he used to be a
coward
and as the night king approached his
brand ready for the kill arya appears
out of nowhere and stabs the night king
completely destroying him in all the
undead he created in the process
remember that by killing the white
Walker you destroy all t or she created
note that he's also killed with a
Valyrian dagger that was given to Arya
by brand himself and bran was given that
dagger from Littlefinger in fact this
dagger was the one that apparently set
off the events of Game of Thrones as it
originally belonged to the assassin who
was sent to kill bran after he was
crippled in season one but there's
something about this scene that just
rubs me the wrong way the night king has
been hyped for seasons upon seasons and
this is how he goes a sneak attack when
he could have just laid back and led his
army obliterate Winterfell and with bran
going into this Warwick stands for the
entirety of the battle which served no
purpose my thoughts are that something
else is at play here what was brand
really doing this whole time is the
night king really dead
or is there something bigger at play but
the final scene of the battle falls on
Melisandre who if you recall is actually
an old hag who's only kept young by the
power of her necklace with her role in
the battle on the undead seemingly over
she removes the necklace and ventures
out into the horizon falling dead her
purpose fulfilled she even said she'd be
dead before dawn and he or she is dying
in front of the actual dawn the Battle
of Winterfell was certainly epic but
what did you guys think I want to hear
your thoughts in the comments below and
if you liked this video make sure to
give it a thumbs up and subscribe
because I have more Game of Thrones
videos on the horizon and remember daddy
loves you very much